تنضم الينا من الخرطوم الشاعراني نضال
الحاج نضال يسعد صباحك استاذ نضال اهلا بك
نورتيني في صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك
معانا
يا هلا يسعد صباحك
صباح العربيه واسعد جدا
الله يسعد ايامك ان شاء الله
اسعد جدا انه ااه هذه
الحيه فيكي اولا الطموح فيك الاسرار وحي
فيكي هذه الامومه نضال يعني كاتبه وصحفيه
وشاعره مقدمه برامج واليوم عدت الى مقاعد
دراسه وتخرجت بامتياز كطبيبه ودي اعرف
اللحظه اللي فكرتي فيها ترجعين لمقاعد
الدراسه
طيب سعيده جدا بهذه الاطلاله واسعد ان
تعبر اللهجه الخارجيه السودانيه
وان يستمع الناس لها عبر صباح العربيه
ااااه الحمد لله رب العالمين هو التوفيق
من ربنا في الاول
ومتى ما وجد الهدف
والعزيمه والاراده ودعم الناس اللي
حوالينا متى ما بيجي النجاح باذن الله
يعني متاح فالحمد لله رب العالمين هي رغبه
في الاول بعدها كي يمكن الوضع الصحي لطفلي
همم ادع لي دافع كبير في انه انا
ارجع الى الدراسه بعدين قطاع عشره سنوات
ويمكن يعني تخرجت قبل لها من ثلاثه كليات
لكن اظل طب طموح
وجود كريم زاد الطموح همم الطموح والحمد
لله استاذ نضال بما انك بدك تحكي بالدارج
السوداني واحنا بنحكي معك كمان احبابكم
عشره ونحبك شديد معنا هون في البرنامج
اليوم نضال يعني عندما يتعلق العمر في
الابناء يعني عيوننا لهم فنحن نفهم موقفك
ونفهم دافع اتجاه ابنك لكنك في كلمه
التخرج يعني شكرتي الدكاتره وقلتي بانهم
كانوا ضوء في ظلمات جهلي فلماذا لم تكتفي
بالاطباء لكي يرعوا ويهتموا بابنك
بالذهبتي ابعد من ذلك وتخصصتي في الطب
نعم وهو يمكن السؤال يكون منطقي اذا انا
كان هدفيه لدراسه الطب هو تقصير الاطباء
انما كان هدافي لدراسه الطب بوجود كريم هو
همم حوجه تقوم لانها تعرف حاله لها ان
تكون مرافق لمريض غير ان تكون طبيب عارف
يعني شنو المريض محتاجينه فيمكن دي واحده
من اهم الاسباب اللي خلتني ادرس الطب
الحاجه الثانيه انه تمنيت انه اخدم ااه من
المنطلق بتاع الطب تحديدا همم يعني زراعه
الخلايا الجذعيه باذن الله اخدم فئه
محتاجه لخدمه همم زي ما كان كريم في وقت
ما محتاج حاجه طب دراسه كانت طويله يعني
نضال ست سنين لتكون طبيبه وتخرجتي بامتياز
ونبارك لك مره ثانيه هل تفكرين بالتخصص
وكيف ستساعدين ابنك في هذه الحاله
الله يبارك بعمري الدراسه كانت طويله
وكانت فيها كثير من التحديات والعقبات
والصعوبات خاصه
لامم ومحاطه باجتماعيات ومحاطه باعمال كده
الحمد لله بفضل الله يمكن كان التخرج
بامتياز يعني بفضل الله
الاخيره
فعلا الموضوع بس محتاج تنظيم وقت وزي ما
قلت جبال الهدف والاراده والعزيمه ودعم
الناس اللي حوالينا ممكن يهون المستحيل
بالنسبه للتخصص باذن الله تعالى في انه
افضل طوالي عشان ما اضيع زمن خاصه انه
التخصص محتاجه سنين كثيره في السودان همم
وقبل التخصص في الامتياز وفي الخدمه وكده
فان شاء الله ربنا يوفقك ان شاء الله لكن
باذن الله ما هو اكثر ان شاء الله
نضال بحكم انك الدكتور شاعره فماذا تقولين
ابيات شعر في حب ابنك
ما سامعه كويس ابيات شعر دكتوره نضال هيك
تحكي لنا اياها اليوم في وصف حب شخص ابنك
حب الاهل
طيب هي كثير من القصائد يمكن جاءت واحده
منها قبل شويه ابوي فانا بهدي ابيات لامي
باقول عنك يوم كتبته كلام الصبح حرف
الكلام مسروق وين يا يما فيك نضمن القوافي
يا حوق وكل الدنيا رجالت الخيول رحلت
وبعدت اي احساس غير هواك في السوق و قالت
زي كلامي عليك قالت زي حديث عليك امي محال
وامي محاله لكن مثل الحلال
طب من نضال دكتوره ونضال شاعره الى نضال
الكاتبه صحفيه حديثين عن تجربتك كاتبها صح
تجربه الكاتب الصحفيه هي اييه كنت كل ما
حسيت انه في فكره الفكره بتسبب ارق كل ما
احس فيه فكره بحيث انه انا محتاجه افرغها
اييه وعشان ما استهلك المفرده الشعريه
بحيث انه ممكن افرغها بلغه اخرى غير
الدارجيه اللي انا بكتب بيهم او بدون ما
تقيدين القافيه او حدود القصيده فكنت بكتب
سرد
ااه بعداك الحمد لله يعني يمكن همم
استاذنا الهندي عز الدين
واستاذه داليا الياس وكثير من الاساتذه
الصحفيين السودانيين شافوا انه تستحق هذه
همم الكلمات انها همم يعني تكتب في الصحف
فكانت في زاويه صحفيه في اخره الحرام
اليوم وبعدها
100 شارع السياسي من 2010 الحمد لله لحد
الحمد لله اول حاجه انا منبهره جدا لانه
بصراحه الخبر بتاع التخرج ما طلع مني
الصفحه الرسميه اللي هي ما شاء الله بتضم
2 مليون انا بحييهم فرد فرد واا انبهرت
لانه الخبر طلع من جهات ثانيه ولقى تفاعل
واسع انا مدينه بشكري عظيم جدا لكل شخص
سوداني
لكل دول افرد من قلبه مساحه لان نضال حسن
الحاج اي ان كانت الشاعره او الصحفيه او
الاعلاميه او حتى
الطبيبه مؤخرا ااه مدينه لهم بيفرحهم لي
وقاعده احس هم هم اسرتي انا باحس الشعب
السوداني كل فرد فيه فرد منه عشان كده
باحترمهم جدا وبحبهم جدا
الصحفيه للحاج نورتينا في صباح العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك يعني